[Musique]
pourquoi la guinée reste engluée dans
cette spirale de coups d'état depuis
l'indépendance jusqu'à présent on était
dans le même cycle politique un état
répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers le détournement de
deniers publics
une volonté de confisquer les attributs
de l'ensemble de la souveraineté c'est
l'adn de la classe politique qui a pris
la place du colon jusqu'à présent le
coup d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas
surpris est-ce que c'était prévisible
pour vous également tu était tout à fait
prévisible
puis deux années même avec monsieur
alpha condé les deux pays étaient dans
une crise profonde à la fin de son
second mandat il a cherché par tous les
moyens y compris de moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21 heures 30 pour décrypter des
grands titres de l'actualité de la
journée au sommaire de ce lundi 8
novembre
la police prise pour cible dernière
attaque en date ce matin devant le
commissariat de cannes un homme un
algérien de 37 ans a été agressé au
couteau quatre policiers à bord de leur
véhicule le parquet anti terroriste
n'ait pas saisi pour l'instant nfr qui
relance la question de la sécurité qu'on
présente souvent comme l'un des grands
enjeux de la présidentielle mais est ce
vraiment le cas et vous vous sentez-vous
en insécurité en france on vous pose la
question ce soir sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france et on en débat dans
quelques instants
on ira ensuite aux états unis qui rouvre
enfin leurs frontières les touristes
vacciner du monde entier peuvent à
nouveau fouler le sol américain
près de 18 mois que certains tendaient
ça des voyageurs vacciner accueillis
alors que l'obligation de vaccins venus
par joe biden dans les entreprises est
suspendu par une cour d'appel fédérale
un revers de taille pour le président
américain analyse en deuxième partie
d'émission avec notre correspondant à
washington est notre invité en plateau
après les vacances de la toussaint les
élèves de 40 départements ont remis le
masque alors qu'il l'avait enlevée il y
a moins d'un mois une décision
gouvernementale justifiée par la
recrudescence de l'épidémie de covin
mais qui suffit parfois de
l'incompréhension emmanuel macron
s'adressera aux français demain soir
pour détailler cette politique sanitaire
le président qui pourraient tenter de
convaincre les anti vaccins justement
dans notre rubrique en pensent les
français nous irons à la rencontre d'un
ambulancier privé de son activité
puisqu'il refuse toujours de se faire
vacciner vous entendrez son témoignage
[Musique]
une attaque à l arme blanche contre des
policiers cela s'est passé ce matin
devant le commissariat central de cannes
dans les alpes maritimes
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est rendu
sur place on retrouve notre reporter
nadège ad razak place beauvau
bonsoir nadège que deal enquête ce soir
sur cette attaque et sur l'assaillant
[Musique]
écoutez stéphanie latte à qui on le
rappelle a eu a eu lieu très tôt ce
matin aux alentours de 6h30 vous l'avez
dit devant le commissariat central de
cannes alors un individu a ouvert la
porte d'un véhicule de police et a
asséné un coup de couteau au niveau du
thorax du conducteur le un autre
policier a alors riposté il a fait usage
de son arme à feu pour et bien venir en
aide à son collègue le secrétaire
départemental du syndicat unité sgp
police fo nous en dit plus sur les
circonstances de cette agression
tout se passe en 12 secondes c'est
rapide 1 12 secondes à ça ça va très
très vite et c'est là qu'on voit vous
savez il ya 26 ans que je fais ce métier
là donc ça fait un petit moment et c'est
là qu'on se dit que les collègues qui
notamment sorte d'école sont pas te
patent aguerris et si on n'est pas guéri
à apprendre des coups de couteau mais en
tout cas ils ont eu un véritable réflexe
qui était qui et salvateur parce que ce
réflexe consiste dans un temps record à
sortir du véhicule et à neutraliser un
individu qui est en train de planter un
collègue ça va très très vite je vous
prie de croire ça va très vite et ils
ont eu vraiment un réflexe
extraordinaire en ce qui concerne
l'assaillant il a rapidement été
neutralisée touché par balle à trois
reprises son pronostic vital est engagé
il est actuellement entre la vie et la
mort en hospitalisé à cannes gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
s'est rapidement rendue sur place et
nous en dit plus en sur le profil de
l'assaillant
à ma connaissance d'assaillants était
régulièrement sur le territoire national
je veux redire qu'il avait un passeport
algérien rentrée sur le continent
européen voilà manifestement plus de dix
ans rentrait en france normalement dans
les années 2016 et il avait demandé
puisqu'il avait un titre de séjour
italien il avait demandé à voir un titre
de séjour français qui pour l'instant ne
lui avait pas été donnée par les
services de la préfecture mais il était
régulièrement soldats et en national ça
monsieur qui travaillait qui a
manifestement entre 35 et 40 ans et qui
était encore une fois en règle de
soldats et en national il n'avait à ma
connaissance aucun casier judiciaire
n'était donc pas connu des services de
police selon les informations que je
moment où je vous parle et ils n'étaient
inscrits dont aucun des fichiers de
radicalisation
l'anc est l' enquête a été confiée à la
police judiciaire de nice qui va tenter
d'apporter des précisions sur
l'agresseur et surtout sur ses
motivations alors le parquet anti le
parquet national anti terroriste n'a pas
encore été saisie de l'enquêté mais elle
à la piste terroriste n'est pour l'heure
pas totalement écartée merci l'adage
abderrazak en direct donc de la place
beauvau et ce week-end c'est aussi le
commissariat d'argenteuil en région
parisienne qui a été une nouvelle fois
la cible de tirs de mortiers à plusieurs
reprises des attaques dont seraient
responsables d'une cinquantaine de
jeunes visiblement en réaction à des
tirs de l bd qui ont blessé un
adolescent plus tôt dans la soirée de
samedi les précisions d'antoine boitel
journée lice pour rt france
50 à 60 jeunes ont pris d'assaut le
commissariat de quartier de la dalle
d'argenteuil dans le val d'oise hier
soir des tirs de mortiers d'artifice ont
été constatés sur place et des images
très impressionnant de cette attaque ont
été diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux
toute la journée nous avons interrogé
jérôme gipn gimenez responsable
communication pour l'unsa police
ile-de-france il a condamné ces attaques
elle a tenu à rappeler que je cite les
habitants de ce quartier populaire sont
les premiers lésés par ces violences
notamment concernant leurs véhicules qui
ont été incendiés ces mêmes véhicules
qu'ils utilisent pour aller travailler
le lendemain qu'ils ont
vraisemblablement été incendié par des
jeune du même quartier le syndicaliste a
qualifié cette attaque de tentative
d'intimidation contre la police après
une intervention qui a eu lieu justement
la veille à argenteuil contre le trafic
de stupéfiants la série suit parfois
surnommé super crs ou forces les plus
rapides a également été appelé en
renfort pour sécuriser le secteur et
éviter une recrudescence des violences
aujourd'hui soit des attaques mais aussi
des provocations envers la police qui se
multiplient à lyon notamment depuis
plusieurs mois les daltons c'est comme
ça qu'on les appelle défient les forces
de l'ordre dans la ville ce groupe
organise des rodéos moto tourner des
clips de rap et envahissent les terrains
le dernier acte des frères dalton
l'escaladent par des leurres de
l'ensemble de la prison de lyon corbas
et après donc ses attaques contre notre
police et autres provocations faut-il
s'inquiéter de la situation sécuritaire
en france vous même vous sentez-vous en
insécurité dans notre pays est ce
réellement une préoccupation des
français au quotidien il est encore le
temps de réagir sur le conte télégramme
berthet france et c'est l'heure de notre
face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler loïc
prud'hommes députés elle est fille de
gironde qui en duplex avec nous bonsoir
loïc peu d'hommes sur ce plateau
d'accueil pierre frédéric billet vert l
air de dreux bonsoir riblier merci
pierre frédéric billets merci d'être
avec nous la police attaqué donc dans
plusieurs villes de france on l'a vu
argenteuil cannes c'est pas une première
malheureusement des actes qui vous
inquiète oui alors vous savez que je
suis fonctionnaire du ministère de
l'intérieur à l'origine donc je connais
bien ces secteurs est et surtout de la
police et c'est vrai qu'on voit se
multiplier des attaques contre les
policiers les gendarmes alors avant il y
avait la peur du gendarme aujourd'hui
cette peur commence à disparaître
sérieusement et l'on s'interroge sur nos
policiers et nos gendarmes dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions il faut
absolument qu'on pourrait y terre le
soutien envers nos forces de police et
les rassurer sur la sécurité qui peuvent
avoir dans le cas de leur métier alors
besoin d'être rassurés loïc prud'hommes
vous ça vous inspire quoi
ses attaques ses provocations leur part
leur ajustement de ses provocations mais
la police n'est plus en sécurité en
france
je crois que c'est la question de la
sécurité est entière qui est interrogée
aujourd'hui dans votre wii une autre
interrogation
précisément et je crois que votre
reportage et vos reportages montrent
comment l'amalgamme finale en de
plusieurs faits assez détaché les uns
des autres créer un sentiment qui
finalement peut s'auto alimenter par eux
selon ce que l'on entend ce que l'on
écoute sur les antennes ici ou là
précisément je me permets de réagir
parce que notre débat justement va plus
loin pour essayer de comprendre si c'est
à un vrai sentiment voire un fait réel
donc on n'essaye pas de faire d'amalgamé
attention c'est précisément l'objet de
notre face à face aujourd'hui d'essayer
de comprendre le vrai du faux
j'entends bien mais ceci dit il ya
beaucoup de situations très différentes
qui ont été présentés je pense qu'on ne
peut pas les mettre même analyse
néanmoins je vais répondre plus
précisément votre question sur
sur les policiers effectivement et je
pense que c'est une problématique il
faut pas regarder uniquement sur ces
faits qui sont gravissimes et que je le
que je dénonce cette attaque notamment
sur le commissariat d'argenteuil et mais
néanmoins ça pose une question plus
large le comment il est arrivé à une
telle distance ion entre la population
de ces quartiers la population en
général en france est finalement une
sorte de
jeu les dires de de défiance vis-à-vis
de la police de la police et j'allais
dire le fait qu'on a coupé la police de
la population est un problème qui
devrait interroger d'abord les élus que
nous sommes et puis la police d'une
manière générale et éroder retrouver ce
lien police population est je pense un
axe de travail qui est essentiel pour
pouvoir trouver les solutions de fond et
pas seulement réagir je veux dire d'une
manière épidermique à des faits ils sont
ici ou là sporadiques et je voudrais qu
on puisse aussi regarder ça d'une
manière générale je pense pas qu'il y
ait de statistiques nous permettent de
dire que finalement de l'insécurité
progresse mais je pense que c'est
effectivement sur le sentiment qu'il
faut que l'on travaille ça vous inspire
quoi justement pierre frédéric biais la
réponse parce que c'est vrai que ce sont
souvent de vision on oppose la vision de
la droite et la vision de la gauche sur
ce terrain là ça sous-entendre et voilà
que quelqu'un a mal fait son boulot
peut-être les autorités dans ce lien qui
est distendu entre la population ou la
police il ya de cela globalement c'est
un sujet majeur de l'élection
présidentielle 93 % des français
estiment que c'est un sujet majeur donc
il faut le prendre en considération faut
pas prendre ça d'un revers de la main ce
serait une erreur à mon avis et puis les
français si vous voulez il ya deux
sujets qui les intéressent il ya des
sujets sur lesquels on a sur la police
tout d'abord parce qu'on va justement et
bien sûr sur la police il faut pas avoir
des théories ont à dire qu'on va
désarmer la police comme un pub lire
jean luc mélenchon c'est pas très
sérieux il ya des préoccupations
qui sont je dirais manifeste la violence
contre les personnes c'est un sujet elle
est en progression depuis des années ça
ses vignes ses émissions des acteurs qui
le dit et puis les vols et les actes
d'incivilité qui sont donc encore une
autre catégorie mais tous ces événements
là effectivement génère un sentiment
d'insécurité mais qui est pas qu à un
sentiment qui est une réalité de terrain
les agressions sexuelles il faut en
parler il ya une augmentation des
agressions sexuelles qui est phénoménal
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à ça en
tout cas on va pour finir sur les
policiers vous rende la parole parce que
je vois que vous voulez réagir loïc
prud'hommes et je voudrais justement
vous faire écouter un policier sous le
choc quand c'est ce que disait gérald
darmanin ce matin la police et est sous
le choc et c'était un soulagement qu'il
n'y ait pas eu de vraie blessés je vous
propose donc l'écouter laurent martin de
frémont secrétaire départemental du
syndicat unité sgp fo police nationale
des alpes maritimes
sachant qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
énormément de comptes à rendre sachant
que nous devons nous justifier pour tous
et pour n'importe quoi et bien les
collègues préfèrent aller vendre des
frites je vous le dis très franchement
et aujourd'hui on se dirige vers des
collègues qui sont au bout du rouleau
parce que le métier devenu un métier
extrêmement difficile loïc prud'hommes
les policiers qui préfèrent aller vendre
des frites on peut considérer qu'ils ne
sont pas entendus ce monsieur poser
aussi la question du contrôle des
polices et qui désormais ce sont un
petit peu voilà observé critique est
votre sentiment
écoutez c'est bien normal qu'il soit
observé de très près puisqu'ils
détiennent la force légitime de l'état
elle ça n'est pas anodin que de tenir ce
pouvoir et donc il faut que ce soit très
contrôlé très encadré et bien sûr que
nous devons très vigilants sur ce qu'ils
font de cette force légitime et donc là
ça pose plutôt la question de la
formation des policiers qu'ils soient
formés affronter les situations qui sont
effectivement difficile mais je pense
qu'elles l'ont toujours été dans toute
l'histoire de la police et que
finalement cette course à l'échalote en
misant ben voilà sur il s'est dès que
l'on évoqué votre invité en plateau sur
la question du menant du désarmement je
pense pas que armée avoir une course à
l'armement permettre de régler ces
problèmes là mais plutôt effectivement
une question des effectifs de police de
commandes ne ils sont formés comment ils
interviennent en effectif suffisant sur
les situations comment on laissait pas
intervenir sur sur des choses qui ne
sont pas en mesure de régler le
cas permis aux solides aux policiers
peut-être de sauver leur vie dans cette
affaire à cannes
oui mais il y aura toujours un cas
particulier et sans doute que une arme
létale
que victime en d'autres notre type 2 de
protection aurait pu également faire
faire cet office donc c'est ce que je
dis aujourd'hui larmes et à celle ci
malheureusement très très loin de la
réalité de terrain savez les policiers
ils sont ils ont affaire aux pires
voyous qu'on puisse trouver sur sur
l'espace public on se fait agresser au
couteau on se fait agresser au couteau
heureusement de policiers portait un
pour un gilet pare balles il n'a pas été
blessé en tout cas physiquement là
dessus ils ont pu riposter de manière
proportionnée parce qu'il allait encore
agressé des policiers dire qu'il faut
qu'une arme n'est pas utile c'est je
vous dis monsieur très gentiment vous
êtes très loin des rites et de terrain
il faut pas être dans l'angélisme si ces
criminels j'aime les gens au travail
j'ai l'idée fausse que si les anglais il
ya plus qu'à un siège qu'est ce que va
devenir de société et donc ce discours
là qui est assise idéologique je pense
que malheureusement c'est assez violent
pour les policiers qui font bien leur
travail parce que nos policiers sont
très bien formés il faut les défendre il
est une réforme à faire au niveau du gpn
je veux bien l'entendre c'est un débat
qu'on peut avoir mais les policiers qu
est ce qu ils sont courageux et en plus
on les culpabilise quand ils utilisent
leurs armes franchement je pense que
c'est irresponsable
le dit prudhomme on a parlé de cfm
dalton c'est pas qu'on a tellement envie
de leur faire de la pub ici mais enfin
quand même c'est vrai qu'il semble un
petit peu effrayé la ville lyon des
rodéos de motos dans le centre-ville
des provocations envers la police
aujourd'hui ils ont grimpé sur le toit
d'une prison le tout relayé allègrement
à parler les réseaux sociaux qu'il a
pour le coup ne pratique aucune censure
ils sont même invités sur des plateaux
télé et je crois bien ce soir c'est
populaire auprès d'une certaine jeunesse
de pardonnez moi l'expression de se
payer du du flic ça nous fait pas peur
vous voilà en l'occurrence il s'agit pas
de ça ils défient simplement l'ordre et
la loi et donc je comprends pas qu'avec
des mesures je vais dire de tank est
temps qu'on ne puisse pas identifier
ces personnes là et les pâtes ford état
de ce que j'ai envie de baisser parce
que voilà lang sur des choses qui sont
effectivement tout à fait en dehors ce
qui est possible et terminera par la loi
je suis pas là il ne semble y attaque
directe de la population le polisario et
pourtant il faut ces choses-là ne
perdure pas les moyens une enquête est
là on a aussi cette problématique je ne
partage pas la situation
du maire de dreux je pense que la
formation des polices il a été recruté
ces derniers temps et joue ceux qui ont
bénéficié des formations longues très
bien formés mais d'entrants ça n'est pas
le cas et puis et puis en plus ils sont
beaucoup occupé dans des tâches
secondaires pour aller chercher la
barrette de shit alors que les moyens
d'investigation leur manque et que c'est
en amont qu'on peut aussi beaucoup
traité de sleipner aujourd'hui font
beaucoup de pourparlers semblent cette
fois à mon sens priori la priorité des
gens des gens il
est pouvoir se déplacer
dans
ce qu'il faut quand même percevoir ces
essais comment les français peuvent
interpréter ce qui se passe vous êtes un
bon français vous travaillez vous êtes
arrêté au bord de la route pour une
annexe i de vitesse on vous met une
amende vous dites oh rien est vrai des
gens comme ça qui se permettent de
mettre des vies en danger avec des
rodéos et on n'arrive pas à régler ce
problème moi je ne comprends pas ce que
fait l'état là dessus
ces gens là c'est une provocation
permanente aux données de gens qui
travaillent et le problème que ça pose
c'est que les français raisonnable ne
commence commence à ne plus croire au
système et c'est là où il ya un danger
donc je vis ça devrait appeler la
conscience de tous les élus les députés
les parlementaires parce que là on a un
problème de foncier
foncièrement qui devient grave ici c'est
que les gens ne croient plus au système
et on doit arrêter ces gens doit les
mettre dans un zoo un tribunal est en
prison justement les gens ils ont
beaucoup réagit sur notre compte rt
france sur ce thème de l'insécurité qui
manifestement fait parler je vous
proposerai un premier message évite
certains quartiers de peur de me faire
agresser on ne peut plus circuler
librement nous dit elle cuistot cécile
j'ai grandi à huit kilomètres de paris
j'avais dans un lycée parisien en train
chaque jour ce serait impossible
aujourd'hui
dernier message j'ai beaucoup voyagé
l'insécurité en france est trop présente
même dans les petites villes louis
prud'hommes pourquoi et comment vous
expliquez ce tel sentiment d'insécurité
grandissant dans notre pays est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ces messages des
choses qui était possible il ya encore
quelques années ne le sont plus
aujourd'hui c'est pas un fantasme ou
c'est la réalité pour vous
je reviens du mal à vous dire que c'est
la réalité moi j'habite en banlieue
d'une grande métropole et
je me déplace
de manière j'allais dire aussi aussi
rassuré que par le passé je n'évite pas
de quartier
n'importe quels quartiers de cette
métropole
néanmoins ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
nier que il ya des problèmes ici ou là
de vols d'agressions
mais je ne pense pas qu'il soit n'est
plus prégnant est il moins prégnant que
auparavant alors tout à l'heure monsieur
le maire disait que sur les agressions
sexuelles et une explosion des chiffres
excluant et je pense qu'il faut regarder
comment ces chiffres sont construits
c'est aussi aujourd'hui que sur ce type
d'agression par exemple et je m'en
réjouis les
les personnes agressées or plus
facilement et permet d'avoir des
plus réelles de ce qui ce qui se passe
dans le pays néanmoins je ne crois pas
qu'on soit dans une espèce de
2,2 de flambée de la violence de la
sécurité où on pourrait croire à
n'importe quel de nos petits villages
est devenu tel chicago infréquentable
donc il faut vraiment faire une
différence entre la réalité la réalité
de ce que l'on pense
être la réalité de nos villes parce
qu'on entend des faits divers qui sont
parfois monté en épingle et puis ce qui
est réellement vécu quotidien les
statistiques qui sont celles qui sont
donc celles de terrain remonter et des
activités de ces problèmes - il me
semble que ne faut pas les les minorer
mais il ne faut pas non plus en faire
l'alpha et l'oméga des politiques et
notamment sur la question de la
présidentielle je pense que c'est c'est
pas la première d insécurité que vivent
mes pensées aujourd'hui néanmoins il
faut la traiter pierre frédéric blaissa
c'est vraiment le grand clivage 1 voilà
entre peut-être la france insoumise et
la droite l air mais aussi la droite
plus dur ce sentiment d'insécurité
une réalité est ce que c'est vrai qu'on
va se poser la question ici est ce que
les médias en font trop esponde mais la
look surtout ce qui va pas et donne
justement ce sentiment d'insécurité
globalement il ya toujours un effet
médiatique outre au travers d'histoires
un petit peu compliqué ou dur et c'est
tout à fait normal parce que 93% des
français estiment que c'est un sujet
majeur donc il faut en parler
après c'est une réalité parce que les
français ne vivent au quotidien quand
vous êtes en ile de france vous prenez
des transports tous les jours sur des
fois des lignes qui seront pas très
fréquentables vous le vivez en pas forcé
leur comportement oui ils nous ont fait
leur comportement on voit aussi que les
femmes se peut s'habiller différemment
selon le dio et ouais ouais bon ça doit
nous interroger aussi bref il ya au delà
des sentiments une réalité qui font
prendre en compte je pense que l'ex
présidentielle c'est une un bon moment
pour mettre ça sur la table il faut
aussi s'interroger si sur comment on
peut se réformer pour être plus efficace
je pense qu'effectivement la police peu
évolué et c'est souhaitable et les
autorités judiciaires je pense par
exemple que tout ce qui est
administration pénitentiaire devrait
être rattachée au ministère de
l'intérieur et tout me sert la justice
parce que on voit bien que dans les
préférences et les arbitrages dans ce
ministère la l'administration
pénitentiaire à des étés depuis 30 ans
complètement oublié il faut leur attaché
mais ce à l'intérieur ça tue d'une
proposition concrète loïc prud'hommes
vos propositions à la france insoumise
justement pour améliorer alors ce
sentiment on va l'appeler puisque pour
vous ce n'est pas nécessairement une
réalité puisque à priori c'est tout de
même l'un des enjeux de cette
présidentielle
mais effectivement je n'ai jamais parlé
déjà tout à l'heure la question ma
formation j'ai déjà dit mais il ya la
question des effectifs et des effectifs
de proximité quand effectivement vous
faites voler votre sac à main ou
fracturés votre voiture et que vous
voyez que avant que vous ayez un
policier où une policière puisque venir
enregistrer enfin qui puissiez vous
recevoir enregistrer votre plainte vous
venir constater c'est parfois très
compliqué parce que les moyens lui nous
font défaut comme beaucoup de services
publics de proximité qui sont essentiels
pour le vivre ensemble et les services
de police ne font pas exception à 100
c'est moi de ne pas vous couper mais
dans certaines de vos mairies les filles
on ne veut pas de vidéo caméra
surveillance par exemple pour traquer
ces ces délinquants quand ils font un
cambriolage par exemple ou parce que les
questions parce que statistiquement et
parce que ça a été déjà documentés par
de nombreuses études la
vidéosurveillance qu'on nous vend sous
vidéoprotection n'a pas n'a pas d'effets
venir à priori de sécurité alors vous
allez voilà du coup avoir sur les
caméras de vidéosurveillance l'avis des
hobbies des dalton qui forme les
imbéciles à lyon et
je vais me permets de vous donner un
chien pour comprendre la situation à à
dreux il ya 25 ans on était en abyme
élégance importante et en 25 ans grâce à
la vidéoprotection et aux efforts
communs de la collectivité de l'état on
a réduit de 40% délinquance alors
qu'elle a augmenté sur le territoire
national 10% ça c'est des chiffres on
n'a quasiment plus de braquage à dreux 1
1 l'an dernier parce que et la
vidéoprotection et comme insécurisés des
voyous c'est ça la réalité de
vidéoprotection c'est pas contre les
gens c'est pour protéger protéger les
gens honnêtes et j'ai pas dit que
c'était contre les genres monsieur le
maire j'étais justement en ce sens en ce
sens leurs protégés par la
vidéoprotection et j'imagine que vous
n'avez pas mis que des caméras si les
effectifs une vraie des gens qui font
leur travail de terrain parce que c'est
là que qu'elle aussi la clé du succès
merci en tout cas à tous les deux on
arrive à la fin de notre face à face aux
prud'hommes merci d'avoir été avec nous
pierre freddy et merci à vous également
et dans le reste de l'actualité en
france des mesures prises aujourd'hui
pour lutter contre les abus sexuels
commis au sein de l'église les fonds
d'indemnisation des victimes sera
financé par les biens de l'église et un
emprunt annonce faite lors d'une
conférence à lourdes en dans les hautes
pyrénées une instance nationale
indépendante de reconnaissance et de
réparation aussi était constitué des
réponses apportées par les évêques
catholiques un mois après la publication
du rapport de la commission sauvé écouté
ce matin les évêques de france ont
décidé
donc d'alimenter ce fonds autant qu il
nécessaire en se dessaisissant de biens
immobiliers et mobiliers de la
conférence des évêques ou des diocèses
et nous prendrons pas l'aider d'argent
du denier de l'église nous ne
l'utilisons pas des fonds que les
fidèles des tons que les idées nous font
pour les missions d'évangélisation pour
d'autres missions qui sont qui sont les
nôtres c'est pourquoi il un fonds dédié
mais nous utiliserons les réserves de
sécurité dont nous pouvons disposer tous
les évêques monde accepte et des idées
même donc d'identifier d'identifiants du
cese les biens immobiliers ou mobiliers
dont ils pouvaient se défait
pourront entrer dans le détail si vous
le voulez nous avons aussi décidé de
silva l'est de souscrire un emprunt pour
pouvoir honorer nos obligations la
politique en france avec une nouvelle
étape pour les républicains en ce moment
à la première confrontation entre les
cinq candidats aient l'air à la
télévision des prétendants en lice pour
le congrès les républicains du 1er et 4
décembre prochain michel barnier xavier
bertrand eric ciotti philippe juvin et
valérie pécresse ont obtenu les 250
parrainage des parrainages qui
permettent de participer à l'élection
interne qui désignera le candidat de la
droite à l'élection présidentielle
réservée aux seuls adhérents du parti et
pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec alexis poulain bonsoir
alexis merci d'avoir rejoint alors ce
soir premier débat des candidats
un débat attendu ça fait un petit moment
cet accouchement se fait voilà peut-être
pas dans la douleur mais en tout cas il
est lent quelles vont être les thèmes
abordés alors il y aura quatre débats
déjà c'est le premier de un mois de
débats donc oui ça va être long il y
aura peut-être une overdose de candidats
à l'air à la fin du mois de novembre en
tout cas ces lycées soit peut-être à
l'usure sans doute ils vont parler bien
sûr de l'immigration et vivent la vente
du pouvoir d'achat évidemment l'économie
qui sera au coeur des débats mais aussi
du régalien l'autorité puisque c'est un
thème de la droite et j'imagine les le
thème central sera celui du pouvoir
d'achat puisqu'on en parle évidemment
beaucoup en ce moment aujourd'hui et
sans doute s'est invitée bien sûr encore
une attaque face à la police donc le
thème de la sécurité qui va être
également centrale à ces débats des
candidats aient l'air alors ils sont
cinq ils ont les parrainages et on va
les voir et demain ils vont se retrouver
tous ensemble d'ailleurs après le débat
autour de la tombe du général de gaulleà
pour montrer combien ils sont soudés
parce que l'exercice est difficile
il s'agit de montrer qu'ils sont pas
d'accord mais qu'ils ne sont pas frères
ennemis voilà donc c'est délicat alors
elle est pas facile parce que coincé
entre le rn10 toujours pas déclaré on
l'attendait sur notre antenne ce soir
mais enfin voilà toujours pas lui aussi
c'est long et macro un couloir étroit
pour une future candidate ou un
boulevard plutôt programmatique oui
alors c'est compliqué pour les
républicains parce que
traditionnellement on entend dire que la
france est à droite donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya un électorat assez puissant et
d et d'ailleurs des régions des villes
des départements enfin vraiment d un
parti qui est ancré dans le territoire
donc pour eux voir l'arrivée d'un
zemmour qui
chamboule totalement la donne qui pousse
tout le monde y compris le rennes le
rennes ils étaient habitués finalement
c'était pas très compliqué une ligne
rouge certains l'avait franchi comme
monsieur mariani eric ciotti maintenant
parle de zemmour donc il y avait
toujours une ligne rouge est floue et
puis emmanuel macron surtout qui a
totalement revu la donne puisqu'il se
fait élire par ce qu'il reste du ps en
quelque sorte avec ce ni droite ni
gauche qui était quand même issue purto
du parti socialiste et il gouverne
depuis 2010 est à droite en volant tous
les thèmes des l'air en essayant de
d'ailleurs d'être colmater les brèches 1
puisqu'il n'était pas très fort sur le
régalien la sécurité la défense la
police et on l'a vu à chaque fois essayé
et bien de montrer qu'il était bon sur
ces thèmes là pour ne pas prêter le
flanc aux critiques donc pour les
républicains évidemment c'est s'est
montré la différence se démarquer tout
en disant qu'ils sont meilleurs alors
qu'ils sont dans l'opposition et c'est
un party les républicains qui n'a pas
l'habitude de l'opposition et on voit
bien ils sont gênés 1 puisqu'ils ne
peuvent pas défendre un bilan montré que
ce qu'ils ont fait est que le bilan
qu'il y a eu il a été siphonné en partie
par emmanuel macron avec des personnes
comme edouard philippe qui lance un
nouveau parti mais aussi bruno le maire
enfin tous les ténors anciennement de la
droite qui sont maintenant au
gouvernement est ce que ça veut dire que
vous êtes en train de nous parler de du
chant du cygne très républicain il ya
encore de l'espoir alors il ya toujours
l'espoir qu'il ya de la vie il ya de
l'espoir et il ya de la vie puisque il
ya de nombreux nouveaux encartés 1 qui
prennent justement leur adhésion au
parti pour pouvoir voter lors du congrès
surtout en région parisienne d'ailleurs
alors est ce que ça va changer la donne
plutôt avantagé valérie pécresse qui est
élu de la région parisienne mais on voit
bien que il ya un vrai schisme profond
qui ne va pas être résolue avec ces
débats celui de savoir si une partie de
la droite centriste va aller avec
emmanuel macron va accepter finalement
pour des postes ministériels ou
simplement parce que le pouvoir est là
et qui menait le maquereau en se
représentant va sans doute faire un
appel du pied une alliance nationale
face à la crise que nous vivons enfin on
connaît un peu la chanson et puis une
autre branche qui regarde du côté d'eric
zemmour pas forcément du rassemblement
national mais
et rim on n'a pas le nom de le pen c'est
un éditorialiste du figaro même s'il a
un discours plus radical que marine le
pen il peut séduire des électeurs de
droite et aussi des politiques de droite
parce que justement égal à cet appel du
pied d'eric zemmour au rpr en disant moi
je veux faire ce retour à cette droite
des valeurs la droite des années 80
l'effort l'économie et puis une ligne
très dur sur l'immigration et je ne vois
pas comment aujourd'hui dans un parti
même si ce soir ils vont débattre
ensemble on va pouvoir mettre à la fois
xavier bertrand et eric ciotti répond
sort dans quelques heures voire quelques
jours voire quelques mois merci alex il
voulait en avoir été avec nous
washington appelle ce soir la
biélorussie à cesser de manipuler les
flux de migrants vers l'europe des
centaines de personnes tentent de
rejoindre la pologne varsovie dénonce
une tentative massive de violation de la
frontière de l'union européenne adrien
fonteneau
ils sont arrivés par centaines à la mi
journée ce lundi et font désormais face
à l'armée polonaise
migrants réfugiés en transit par la
biélorussie ces personnes espère passer
la frontière et atteindre la pologne une
tentative dénoncée par les autorités
polonaises
gratuit nous sommes aujourd'hui
confrontés à la situation la plus
difficile depuis le début de la crise à
la frontière entre la pologne et la
biélorussie
nous avons affaire à un autre élément de
cette guerre hybride comme vous le savez
plusieurs centaines de personnes
s'approchent actuellement de la
frontière ils sont amenés à travers le
territoire de la biélorussie par des
personnes associées aux services de
sécurité biélorusse il s'agit d'une
action organisée dont nous avons eu
connaissance grâce aux informations
reçues par nos services johnny chan aux
racines à port neuf
tu m'as où la chasse aux bugs un
discours partagé par les instances
internationales
depuis plusieurs semaines bruxelles
accuse le président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko d'avoir orchestré l'arrivée
de ces migrants venus principalement du
moyen-orient des vagues migratoires qui
serait organisée pour protester contre
l'union européenne et selon elle en
réponse aux sanctions infligées à la
biélorussie
l'utilisation des migrants par le régime
loukachenko comme tactique hybride est
inacceptable nous sommes préoccupés par
la récente escalade à la frontière entre
la pologne et le bélarus nous appelons
le bélarus à respecter le droit
international
à l'issue d'une réunion de crise mené ce
lundi après midi par le président
polonais andrzej dida et ses principaux
ministres la situation a été déclarée
sous contrôle
dans l'actualité internationale moscou
qui dénonce les appels à ne pas
reconnaître la présidentielle au niger
agua ou lendemain du scrutin l'union
européenne a pointé du doigt un régime
autocratique dans un communiqué
l'espagne met en cause l'absence de
légitimité du scrutin selon des premiers
résultats partiels le président sortant
daniel ortega a été réélu pour un
quatrième mandat avec 75% des voix ses
détracteurs dénoncent la répression de
l'opposition
mais la loi zunie
scènes de liesse à managua où les
partisans de daniel ortega célèbre la
victoire du président sortant qui va
diriger le nicaragua pour cinq nouvelles
années
grâce à dieu le nicaragua l'a emporté le
peuple a triomphé en soutenant le
commandant daniel ortega le meilleur
président qui eut le nicaragua
la réélection du dirigeant de 75 ans ne
faisait aucun doute mais ce nouveau
mandat en laisse plus d'un sceptique
en effet depuis 2018 le pouvoir en place
muzet l'opposition de nombreux
adversaires politiques d'ortega ont été
emprisonnés et les cinq candidats
inscrits pour affronter le chef de
l'état ne sont autres que des proches de
ce dernier des accusations réfutées par
le principal intéressé juste après avoir
voté ah ok c'est un commencé
même s'il s'habille comme ils
s'habillent ce sont des démons ce sont
des démons qui ne veulent pas la paix
qui ne veulent pas la tranquillité pour
notre pays et qui optent pour la
violence pour la guerre pour la
disqualification pour la calomnie pour
les campagnes pourquoi
pour que le nicaragua soit de nouveau
plongé dans des affrontements violents
alors que les bureaux de vote fermaient
leurs portes hier soir beaucoup avaient
décidé de ne pas aller voter pour
protester contre ce qu'ils qualifient de
cirque orale il ya dont le fils de 15
ans a été tuée lors des manifestations
contre le gouvernement au printemps 2010
8 fait partie de ceux là
il n'y a pas eu de justice il n'y a rien
eu parce que vous savez comment nous
sommes avec le régime de daniel ortega
pour lui c'est mort n'existe pas il n'y
a pas eu de décès il n'y a pas eu
d'assassinât et il n'y a pas de
prisonniers politiques
et parmi ceux qui n'ont pas perdu la vie
beaucoup se sont exilés le jour même de
l'élection présidentielle c'est depuis
les états unis ou encore le costa rica
que de nombreux citoyens ont exprimé
leur colère
nous sommes fatigués de vivre en exil
fatigué que notre pays soit prise en
otage que nos prisonniers politiques
soit emprisonné pour quelque chose
qu'ils n'ont pas commis nous voulons la
démocratie au nicaragua que la
communauté internationale s'exprime et
fassent quelque chose pour que nous
autres nicaraguayen puissions retourner
dans notre pays pour que cette farce qui
n'est reconnu ni par la communauté
internationale ni par les nicaraguayens
prenne fin
la diaspora nicaraguayenne n'est pas la
seule à critiquer ces élections le
président américain joe biden lui aussi
a dénoncé vigoureusement ce scrutin ce
que le président du nicaragua et son
épouse la vice-présidente rosario
murillo ont orchestré aujourd'hui est
une élection pantomine qui n'étaient ni
libres ni justes et certainement pas
démocratique héros de la révolution
daniel ortega est aujourd'hui accusé par
ses opposants d'agir de la même façon
que le dictateur anastasio somoza qu'il
a contribué à renverser en 1979
est selon moscou l'élection
présidentielle s'est déroulée dans le
respect de la loi le chef de la
diplomatie russe s'est exprimé ce matin
hier soir à l'issue des élections au
nicaragua la maison blanche a refusé de
les reconnaître et a appelé tous les
autres pays à faire de même nous
considérons que cela est inacceptable et
nous condamnons fermement une telle
politique conformément à la constitution
du nicaragua ainsi qu'aux constitution
d'autres pays d'amérique latine de pays
d'autres régions du monde et y compris
conformément à la constitution des états
unis le peuple est détenteur de la
souveraineté et seul le peuple en
l'occurrence le peuple nicaraguayen a le
droit de juger de la légitimité du
processus électoral dans son propre pays
le gui team no steve blake no
string
chili le président sebastian pinera a
menacé de destitution par l'opposition
une procédure a été lancée dans la
foulée des pandores paper selon keith
international a révélé la vente par la
famille pinera d'une compagnie minière
est réalisé dans un paradis fiscal
le parlement chilien pourrait se
prononcer aujourd'hui les détails en
images
[Musique]
les voyageurs vaccinées peuvent à
nouveau posé le pied sur le sol
américain après 18 18 mois de fermeture
les frontières des états unis sont
rouvertes une très bonne nouvelle pour
les touristes et pour les compagnies
aériennes les avions affiche complet et
les prix s'envolent comme les avions
antoine ogier mes disques et fit
une preuve de vaccination est un test
qu'ovide négatif c'est ce qu'il faudra
désormais pour se rendre en avion aux
états unis un soulagement pour les
compagnies aériennes comme air france
qui voit en la réouverture des
frontières américaines un moyen de
redresser leurs activités
on l'attend depuis longtemps c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour air france et
plus globalement pour le groupe air
france klm puisque l'atlantique nord est
notre principal réseau long courrier
avant le coc vide et leur présenter
quand même 40 % de nos revenus long
courriers sur l'ensemble du groupe les
compagnies européennes qui sont les
premières à bénéficier du marché aérien
américain avec plus de 73 millions de
passagers en 2010 9 espère rapidement
retrouvé leur niveau d'avant crise d'ici
mars 2022 air france prévoit de revenir
à 90 % de ses capacités sur les états
unis contre 65% en octobre l'annoncé de
la réouverture des frontières a
immédiatement suscité un afflux de
réservations
de quoi ravir les professionnels du
voyage c'est une excellente nouvelle que
les états unis rouvrent leurs frontières
aux voyageurs entièrement vacciner du
royaume uni et de lieu à partir du 8
novembre les entreprises de voyage et de
tourisme des deux côtés de l'atlantique
vont pouvoir pousser un soupir de
soulagement les visiteurs de lieux et du
royaume uni ont contribué pour plus de
40 6 milliards de dollars à l'économie
américaine en 2010 f montrant à quel
point cette décision sera cruciale pour
la reprise américaine
pour les compagnies américaines aussi
cette réouverture est une bénédiction au
lendemain de son annonce le 15 octobre
dernier american airlines a vu ses
réservations bondir de 66% vers le
royaume uni 2 40% vers l'europe est de
74% vers le brésil en conséquence les
compagnies aériennes prévoient
d'augmenter leurs capacités tant en
nombre de vols que de sièges disponibles
mais après les vastes plans de
restructuration du début de la pandémie
c'est le manque de personnel qui
pourrait poser problème et ouverture des
frontières aux états unis donc pour les
touristes vacciner alors qu'à
l'intérieur du pays la politique
sanitaire est contestée dans certains
états une cour d'appel fédérale a
suspendu ce week-end l'obligation
vaccinale dans les entreprises une
mesure voulue par le gouvernement byden
c'est donc un nouveau revers pour le
président américain pour en parler on
retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir tout va
sur quoi repose cette décision de
suspendre cette mesure défendue par le
président
c'est une décision d'une cour d'appel
fédéral de la nouvelle orléans les juges
estiment qu'il y a des arguments
laissant croire qu'il y a de sérieux
problèmes constitutionnels et
procéduraux concernant donc la mesure
gouvernementale annoncée la semaine
dernière par joe biden une plainte avait
été déposée dans la foulée notamment par
des représentants républicains parmi eux
le procureur général de louisiane ou
encore le gouverneur républicain de
l'état du texas a tous deux se sont
félicités de la suspension de la mesure
annoncée par joe biden écouter
alertait la cour d'appel fédérale vient
de suspendre temporairement le mandat du
vaccin de baden des audiences d'urgence
auront lieu prochainement nous aurons
notre journée devant les tribunaux pour
annuler l'abus d'autorité
inconstitutionnel de baden
l'action de la cour empêche non
seulement byden d'aller de l'avant avec
son ex est illégal mais commande
également l'examen judicieuse que nous
avons demandé by donne n'imposera pas de
procédures médicales au peuple américain
sans les freins et contrepoids prévu par
notre compte tution
cette mesure d' obligation vaccinale
annoncé par joe biden était la dernière
étape en date pour tenter d'accélérer la
campagne de vaccination aux etats unis
une obligation de vaccination pour des
millions d'employés dans le pays pour
tous ceux qui travaillent dans des
entreprises qui emploient de plus plus
de 100 salariés avec toutefois la
possibilité pour ceux qui refuseraient
de se faire vacciner de se faire tester
régulièrement alors les autorités
américaines estiment aujourd'hui
qu'elles vont défendre cette mesure
devant la justice et elles se disent
confiantes sur l'avenir légal de ce
dispositif écouté par exemple les
détails donnés il ya quelques instants à
peine par la porte parole de la maison
blanche
le ministère du travail a la
responsabilité de garantir la sécurité
des travailleurs et dispose de
l'autorité légale pour le faire le
ministère du travail détermine les
travailleurs à risque où confronté à ce
qu'on appelle un grave danger et si vous
regardez autour de vous et si nous
faisons le bilan de ces dernières années
plus de 750 mille personnes sont mortes
du que vides aujourd'hui il y a environ
1300 personnes par jour qui continue
d'en mourir si ce n'est pas un grave
danger je ne sais pas ce que c'est
pour le dire simplement il s'agit
d'assurer la sécurité des personnes sur
leur lieu de travail et il est crucial
est important de le faire et c'est le
message que nous voulons faire passer
la maison blanche estime qu'il y a
urgence à augmenter le nombre de
vaccinés aux états unis elle se sert
aussi des exemples d'entreprises
américaines qui ont mis en place des
dispositifs d'obligations de vaccination
la maison blanche explique que dans ces
entreprises le nombre de vaccinés a
grimpé en flèche mais vous avez aussi
des personnes qui s'opposent à cette
obligation de vaccination qui explique
qu'il ya des problèmes d'effectif dans
un certain nombre d'entreprises qui ont
justement mis en place ces obligations
de vaccination on peut rappeler
notamment le cas de cette
compagnie aérienne southwest airlines
qui avait dû annuler des milliers de
vols par manque justement d'effectifs
même si on sait que la direction de
cette compagnie aérienne à tout toujours
nié tout lien entre ces problèmes
d'effectifs et la mise en place d'
obligation vaccinale merci thomas vous
restez avec nous si vous le voulez on va
accueillir à notre invité geraldo
ollivier journaliste franco américain
qui nous a rejoints dans nos studios
bonsoir gérald olivier merci d'être avec
nous
vous connaissez évidemment beaucoup
mieux les états unis que nous par
définition joe biden est en réelle
rupture avec cet esprit très américain
de libéralisme il veut tenter d'imposer
certaines choses en tout cas c'est vécu
comme tel par certains américains
aujourd'hui oui en fait c'est une
question d'être extract extrêmement
complexe parce qu'elle dépasse le cadre
médical c'est à dire que vous avez à la
fois la question du rapport entre le
gouvernement fédéral et les états
techniquement la santé est du ressort
des états donc le gouvernement ne peut
pas imposer au plan national une
obligation fédérale ce sont les états
qui peuvent le faire en leur propre jeu
dire à leurs propres frontières
de même que le gouvernement américain
veut vraiment fédéral ne peut pas
imposer un certain nombre de règles et
demandé aux entreprises dad imposer ses
règles elle même surtout si ces règles
s'imposent à des entreprises de plus de
100 personnes et que d'autres règles
s'imposent à des entreprises de moins de
100 personnes donc en fait là on a une
série de niveaux à partir desquels on
peut défier cette loi mais il ya deux
choses qui sont en train de se produire
la première c'est qu'on voie clairement
derrière le gouvernement fédéral
derrière les autorités médicales du cdc
ou du mih qui sont les deux grandes
autorités médicales aux états unis on a
une volonté d'aller vers une forme de
vaccination systématique contre le coc
vide de même qu'elles existent déjà
aujourd'hui contre la polio contre la
variole contre la rubéole obligatoire
qui apparemment sont en tout cas
exactement en tout cas on se base là
dessus est en avance dans ce sens là si
ce n'est que je pense que là le
gouvernement a voulu aller un petit peu
trop vite parce que il passe par une
régulation du travail et que l'agent ce
qui impose cette régulation donc l'
agence de la sécurité au travail cette
agence qui appartient au secrétariat du
travail aux etats-unis ne peut pas
imposer une règle sans que celle-ci
passe par le processus législatif
c'est-à-dire par le congrès donc cette
loi elle est en train d'être défié à
plusieurs niveaux et pour l'instant
l'administration byden a avancé son
premier pion et puis les cours ont
répandu en mettant en suspension de
l'application puis y aura une troisième
étape et une 4e et on n'est pas sorti de
ce processus ça va être très long il n'y
a pas vraiment de surprise dans la
mesure où joe biden avait annoncé la
couleur on se souvient pendant la
campagne il était extrêmement poser à la
vision qu'avaient donald trump 1 de
cette gestion du duc au vide est-ce que
d'une certaine manière je vous demande
pas parler de droit mais d'une certaine
manière cette initiative est justifiée
dans le sens du sanitaire ce qui est
ironique dans cette histoire c'est que
lorsque le coc vide est apparu pour la
première fois l'administration trump en
était en février mars 2020 on était
alors à l'époque en campagne électorale
et c'est l'admiration de
l'administration trump qui a misé sur le
tout vaccinal avec cette fameuse
opération war speed à travers laquelle
le président trump a imposé en quelque
sorte au au laboratoire de trouver un
vaccin d'ici six à neuf mois et ils y
sont parvenus et décembre 2020 les
premiers vaccins ont été approuvés juste
avant vous aviez eu l'élection le
changement d'administration est une
sorte d'un versement je dirais des
rapports au vaccin parce que tant que
trump était président les démocrates à
disait méfiez vous de ce qu'on est en
train de vous préparer une fois que 30
n'est plus président que c'est
l'administration by donne qui vient
c'est l'administration de biden qui
prend le relais et qui cherche à imposer
ce tout vaccinal et ce sont les
républicains et les états républicains
qui résistent en disant ce n'est pas à
notre gouvernement de nous dire comment
nous comporter donc c'est là où il ya
une certaine ironie maintenant ce qui se
passe malgré tout c'est que le coït
perdure il ya 750 mille décès aux états
unis il ya plus d'américains qui sont
mort du co vide en 2021 que ne sont
morts en 2020 et comme le disait votre
reportage récemment il ya encore mille
cas de décès pratiquement tous les jours
dont s'est absolument énorme et c'est
pourquoi l'administration by not cherche
à trouver un moyen de protéger et de
stopper et que pour eux le vaccin est ce
moyen le plus efficace très tôt ma bonne
et justement cette situation sanitaire
aux états unis gerald lui et a commencé
en nous en parler mais elle ne s'arrange
pas franchement n'est ce pas
oui il ya donc plus de 750 mille morts
aux etats unis ce qui est un chiffre
évidemment considérable il faut rappeler
que la campagne de vaccination avait
commencé très fort aux états unis puis
elle s'est essoufflée au point que
l'objectif affiché de joe biden d'un
certain nombre de la population vaccinée
en date du 4 juillet jour de
l'indépendance américaine n'avait pas
été atteint c'était bien la preuve que
cette campagne de vaccination s'était
essoufflé assez rapidement et c'est pour
cela que l'administration de joe biden
veut durcir la politique en matière
d'obligation vaccinale on voit de plus
en plus de mesures qui sont prises en ce
sens en ce moment mais il ya plus
généralement un problème de fracture
entre une partie de la population et
donc la parole officielle il ya par
exemple la figure d'anthony fochi qui
est le conseiller santé de la maison
blanche qui est assez clivant qui est
souvent remis en question par une partie
des américains il ya donc un vrai fossé
qui s'est créé et c'est pour cela
qu'elle est l'administration byden peine
à convaincre davantage d'américains de
se faire vacciner et c'est le sens de
ses obligations de vaccination justement
pour augmenter le nombre d'américains
vacciner j'ai un de dévier c'est un peu
comme en france ce que nous dira
finalement thomas bonnet un vrai clivage
dans la population il ya les anti
vaccins et voilà ceux qui y vont ma foi
de mon cas oui je sais pas si ça aussi
tranchée qu'en france parce qu'en fait
le problème aux états unis c'est que
vous avez quand même au delà de 50
millions d'américains qui ont été
touchés par le co lead et dont la
plupart d'ailleurs heureusement ont
survécu et donc parmi ces 50 millions
d'américains y en a qui s'estiment
posséder cette immunité naturelle du
fait qu'ils ont eu
comme on dirait qu'ils ont eu le virus
et qu'ils ont survécu donc ils sont pas
forcément anti vaccins mais ils estiment
qu'ils ne doivent pas être vaccinés
parce qu'ils ont déjà cette immunité au
sein du monde politique on est beaucoup
plus d'accord les républicains en
général pour défendre l'idée de ce fac
de se faire vacciner pour des questions
de santé par contre ils voient aussi
défendre la liberté des états à gérer ce
qui leur revient et la liberté des
individus à gérer leur vie comme ils
l'entendent tout le tout le paradoxe ici
si vous voulez c'est que si vous décidez
de ne pas vous faire vacciner vous vous
exposez vous même au virus techniquement
vous ne menacer personne en étant vous
même pas vacciner vous êtes juste moins
bien protégée à partir de là les
critères habituels qui consiste à
imposer un comportement au nom de la
protection des autres ne s'applique pas
à ce virus d'où une complication
supplémentaire
thomas von est justement par les
politiques ja il ya évidemment des
choses éminemment politique là en
dessous notamment le gouvernement
gouverneur pendant du texas un qui a
pris part à ce débat déjà opposé
l'obligation de porter un masque là il
avait interdire à la mi-octobre
l'obligation vaccinale sur son sol c'est
une fronde et des républicains qui
s'intensifie dans le cadre d'une fronde
plus globale
mais votre invité a tout à fait raison
ces leaders républicains ne sont pas
opposés à la vaccination en revanche ils
sont très attachés aux libertés
individuelles
c'est pour ces raisons qu'il ne veulent
pas imposer d'obligations quelles
qu'elles soient dans leur état il ya
deux personnalités qui incarnent cette
opposition en réalité aux obligations
c'est greg abbott le gouverneur
républicain du texas et ron de santis
qu'est le gouverneur républicain de
floride ils se sont opposés à de très
nombreuses reprises à l'obligation de
vaccination évidemment mais aussi du
port du masque dans les écoles c'est
d'ailleurs une thématique qui s'est même
retrouvé lors de la campagne pour les
élections gouvernent pour le gouverneur
en virginie puisque le candidat
républicain a beaucoup utilisé
l'argument de la fermeture des écoles en
période de qu'ovide contre son
adversaire démocrate c'est un argument
qui avait trouvé un fort écho dans la
population notamment auprès des parents
donc évidemment il ya un aspect
politique même s'il faut rappeler que la
plupart des élus républicains ne sont
pas anti vaccins mais qu'ils sont
simplement attachés à la liberté
individuelle des individus il faut aussi
rappeler qu'il y à une certain nombre de
protestations qui ont eu lieu notamment
dans la ville de new york où il ya sans
doute les règles les plus strictes du
pays en matière de vaccination là aussi
vous avez eu des oppositions de la part
d'employés municipaux qui ne souhaitent
pas se plier à cette obligation de
vaccination oui gérald olivier merci à
thomas cherhal d'olivier oui voilà
chante y avoir d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
votre journaliste à washington et si je
devrais juste en rajouter pour une
petite seconde y a pas que des états
républicains vous avez de cet état qui
ont déposé un recours contre cette loi
est derrière c est à vous avez parfois
des associations civiques des groupes
religieux des associations d'affaires
donc là cette loi est contesté à
plusieurs niveaux mais là où vous avez
raison c'est de parler de fraude parce
que justement il ya une sorte d'alliance
qui dépasse le simple cadre politique ou
le cadre des parties contre contre cette
loi bâillon donne dernière petite
question ça doit certainement vous faire
plaisir ça y est on peut retourner aux
états unis 18 mois c'était très long
alors que les américains venaient
allègrement visiter l'europe on est
soulagé on est content c'est c'est
normal en tout cas c'est mieux sérieux
que ça fait en dépit de ce qu'on vient
de dire malgré tout le virus circule et
saissac et c'est ça qui est essentiel et
puis retrouver une vie aussi normale que
possible c'est à dire pouvoir voyager
oui c'est important aux états unis on
était un petit peu jaloux les voir dans
les rues de paris et pas pouvoir aller
aux états unis comme on voulait en tout
cas merci gérald olivier merci également
thomas bonnin d'avoir été avec nous
restez avec nous donc quelques instants
nous parlerons de la rentrée masquer un
a là aussi devant des élèves de 39
départements alors qu'on leur avait en
lui et ce même à ce qu'il y a moins d'un
mois une décision gouvernementale
justifiée par la recrudescence de
l'épidémie de covin mais qui suscitent
parfois de l'incompréhension
[Musique]
chine etats unis union européenne les
pays n'ont pas lésiné sur les milliards
pour tenter de remettre à flot des
économies malmenées par la pandémie de
kobe 19 les plans de relance ccht de la
croissance avec de la bête toutes les
annonces de relance ont servi deux
raisons supplémentaires ou d'arguments
supplémentaires pour faire monter les
bourses pourquoi parce que notamment ont
continué les politiques de quantitative
easing c'est à dire d'injections
massives de liquidités et là on voit
bien il ya il ya erreur de casting et
comment peut-on penser que le
quantitative easing est la réponse à
tous nos maux si on a enfin une vision
etc ont mis sur les les bonnes les
bonnes choses eh bien peut-être que on
aura un plan de relance intéressant mais
sinon facile ou les c'est encore une
fois de l'argent jeté par les fenêtres
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une charité hopitalisés il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
de coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes ce qui nous alertent nous c'est
la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui est gay accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
son diagnostic et le traitement et non
pas sur la prévention et on est dans un
système très curatif 1 c'est essentiel
d'avoir l'information pour pas subir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la communication emmanuel mapon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
victhom est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule il est où ça n'a
plus rien fait pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
il pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique dont il désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus cooney sq justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour ça comme politique
personnelle est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
aider dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire après les vacances de la
toussaint les élèves de 39 départements
remis le masque alors qu'ils avaient
enlevées il ya moins d'un mois une
décision gouvernementale justifiée par
la recrudescence de l'épidémie de covin
mais qui suffit parfois de
l'incompréhension emmanuel macron
s'adressera aux français demain soir ils
pourraient tenter de convaincre les anti
vaccins justement dans notre rubrique en
pensent les français ce soir nous sommes
allés à la rencontre de l'un d'entre eux
un ambulancier privé son activité
puisqu'il refuse toujours de se faire
piquer
[Musique]
le masque à nouveau obligatoire à
l'école primaire depuis ce lundi pour
lutter contre le coc vides sont
concernées 40 départements où le taux
d'incidence est supérieure à 50 pour
cent mille habitants l'épidémie reprend
depuis plusieurs jours sur le territoire
de quoi inquiéter emmanuel macron qui
s'adressera aux français demain soir les
détails avec quentin mots clairs et
amaya souper
nouvelle rentrée des classes masqué pour
de nombreux élèves du primaire les
vacances de la toussaint terminé le
masque devient obligatoire à l'école
dans 40 départements
une nouvelle mesure dont s'accommode les
élèves plutôt facilement même si
l'apprentissage on devient plus
compliqué pour les enfants en bas âge
je pense qu'ils s'habituent les enfants
sont plus dociles des roms que les
adultes et c'est vrai qu'ils se sont
habitués ils le savent après il s'est
habitué maintenant ne plus la voir donc
je pense que demain quel jeu les avoir
en place ça va être la réaction pourquoi
il faut qu'on remette le masque enfin
c'est une contrainte à la communication
il faut parler plus fort il faut
accentuer plus les mots même nom en tant
qu'enseignant il faut il faut articuler
davantage en a et puis c'est quand même
une barrière de la communication donc
il faut que jacques senti aussi au
niveau des ses yeux pour qu'il comprenne
quelquefois une mesure accueillie de
manière mitigée par les élèves leurs
parents je pense que c'est dramatique
pour les enfants mais que je pense que
si il en arrive là c'est pour qu'on
évite de vacciner les enfants je suis
favorable j'ai remarqué que depuis
qu'elle porte le masque à la moins
souvent de maladies de riz de rhumes de
de gastro enfin toutes ces malaises
petite maladie donc je suis plutôt
favorable au port du masque à l'école
mais nécessaire pour freiner l'épidémie
selon jean michel blanquer
il s'agit d'une règle que nous avons
établies dès la fin du mois d'août on a
dit qu'on ferait évoluer le curseur en
fonction de la situation sanitaire c'est
exactement ce que nous faisons plus que
ces départements sont repartis à la
hausse en termes de taux d'incidence
évidemment c'est désagréable pour tout
le monde mais c'est nécessaire et chacun
le comprend c'est 40 départements
viennent s'ajouter aux 21 territoire où
le port du masque à l'école n'avait pas
été levé
autre signe d'une reprise épidémique le
nombre de personnes actuellement
hospitalisé en soins critiques augmente
sensiblement plus 55 patients en une
semaine c'est dans ce contexte qu'ils
emmanuel macron prendra la parole mardi
soir une allocution pour donner le ton
de la saison hivernale
reconfirme ans et couvre feu ne sont pas
à l'ordre du jour la france étant plutôt
épargné pour le moment par rapport à
d'autres pays européens
le président de la république devrait
tenter de persuader les non-vaccinés de
passer à l'acte par de nouvelles mesures
avec près de 75% des français ayant
terminé leur schéma vaccinal le pays
possède l'un des taux de vaccinations
les plus élevés au monde mais la
troisième injection peine toujours à
convaincre au 2 novembre
seulement moins de 20 % des plus de 65
ans avait reçu une dose de rappel
le gouvernement français qui a toujours
du mal à convaincre une partie des
français sur la nécessité de se faire
vacciner dans notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français nous allons ce soir
à la rencontre de jean bernard hinault
un ambulancier ou plutôt ex ambulanciers
puisqu'il a refusé de se faire vacciner
de puissance et enbil est suspendu une
décision qu'il ne comprend pas car il
était prêt à faire des tests et a décidé
donc de porter l affaire en justice
reportage katia technique sébastien
dufour
je suis à châteaubriant loire-atlantique
aujourd'hui je rencontre jean bernard
qui est ambulanciers privés mais en ce
moment il ne travaille plus pour jean
bernard comment allez vous bonjour bas
ça pourrait aller mieux mais voilà oui
en effet je ne travaille plus depuis le
20 septembre dernier puisque j'ai été
suspendu de toutes fonctions
car la loi du 5 août m'oblige à me faire
vacciner je suis contre contre le le
fait de me faire vacciner mais toujours
est il sait que ben il le faut pour que
je puisse exercer ma profession ce qui
veut dire je n'ai plus du tout de
ressources financières
donc j'ai encore moins droit au rsa -
droit des allocations chômage donc je
peux vous dire que tous les jours c on
se serre la ceinture et c'est très très
dur que ressentez-vous jean-bernard en
revenant ici parce que cet hôpital c'est
votre environnement de travail
ça me manque ça me manque énormément ce
travail parce que c'est vrai que quand
je l'exerçais j'étais comme un poisson
dans l'eau et
c'est un métier qui est dur mais moi je
m'en suis jamais plaint au contraire
j'ai toujours pris ce métier avec le
sourire mais depuis le 20 septembre je
les plus sourire puisque j'exerce ce
métier
qui était vraiment
je dirais le centre g dans les veines
quoi et bon j'ai le coeur sur la main
c'est tout ça qui me manque à l'heure
actuelle et puis les relations que
j'avais avec le personnel soignant d'ici
mes collègues qui me manque et puis
vraiment le contact avec les gens que je
n'ai n'est plus et apporter ce que je
mon savoir faire
notamment en terme dans les relations
d'urgence ou quand on est appelé par le
samu puisqu'on est mandaté dans notre
métier pour faire des opérations
d'urgence
le fait voilà d'apporter de l'aide à des
gens qui sont en gérant difficulté ça me
manque énormément énormément est ce que
vous sentez incompris en fait tout à
fait on se sent complètement mis sur la
touche
2 par 2 par une ma direction déjà qui
depuis le 20 septembre ne m'a donné
aucune nouvelle le fait aussi de ne pas
côtoyer mes collègues qui m'ont un peu
je dirais mis de côté alors on se sent
un petit peu
comme des pestiférés j'ai pas le mot et
est un peu fort mais c'est ce que je
ressens actuellement c'est peut-être
parce qu'on veut me faire ressentir mais
moi je me sent exclue de tout et quand
on voit qu'on nous prive de toutes nos
libertés on peut même pas aller prendre
un verre dans un café on peut même pas
aller prendre deux allées dans un petit
restaurant sans présenter un papier
c'est priver le monde de sa liberté quoi
mais écoutez moi ce que je vous propose
c'est de venir chez moi pour je vous
explique un petit peu plus profondément
dans la citation on y va
jean bernard comment elle vous appris
votre suspension eh bien écoutez je suis
revenu de congé le 20 septembre et donc
j'ai été reçu par mon responsable qui
m'a demandé si j'avais les documents
qu'il fallait pour continuer à exercer
mon métier je lui ai dit que j'avais
même bien mon pass sanitaire puisque
j'avais un test pcr que j'avais effectué
le vendredi donc j'étais
de ce côté là j'étais couvert on va dire
et quand il m'a demandé à voir mon
schéma vaccinal j'ai refusé de lui
montrer au prétexte qu'il n'avait aucun
aucun lien avec le secret médical donc
suite à ça il m'a dit tu refuses je te
tu connais la sanction tu vas être
suspendue donc je suis rentré chez moi
est dépité j'ai commencé à
une grève de la faim et le lendemain
donc le 21 à 21h jeu j'ai eu la bonne
surprise d'avoir une convocation à la
visite médicale et au bout de cette
visite médicale j'en suis ressorti avec
un certificat d'aptitude
ce qui voulait dire que la suspension
devenait automatiquement illégal donc
bientôt vous allez vous retrouver au
tribunal ce un soulagement pour vous
d'en arriver là au moins d'être entendu
c'était ce que j'attendais et ben là je
n'ai qu'une hâte ses dettes d'être
devant ce juge au référé et d'exposer
vraiment mes arguments
jean-bernard ça vous inspire quoi votre
mésaventure au final
disons que c'est ça a réveillé en moi
mon
ma combativité je pensais pas être aussi
fort que ça moralement vous êtes prêts à
vous battre jusqu'au bout a tout à fait
oui je suis rentré dans ce combat c'est
pas pour abandonner en plein milieu de
la bataille je suis déterminé déjà à me
battre pour mon propre dossier me faire
entendre et tenter d'obtenir gain de
cause et je suis également
déterminé à aider l'ensemble de mes
collègues de la profession tous les
personnels soignants qui sont dans la
rue et j'espère que le gouvernement
entendra enfin
notre colère notre nos interrogations et
pourquoi pas essayer de nous comprendre
et voilà donc pour ce témoignage d'un
français qui est en guerre avec le passé
ni terre passe qui a donc été prolongé
la semaine dernière par l'assemblée
nationale jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 alors
qu'attendre de l'allocution du président
de la république on vous pose la
question ce soir sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france on parle aussi du passé
ni terre pour ou contre c'est l'objet de
notre face à face
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
l'eau quand laurent jacot bélie porte
parole de marine le pen candidate du
rassemblement national à la prise en
selle 2022 bonsoir à vous à vos côtés
philippe mazuel président du parti les
citoyens vous êtes également candidat à
la présidentielle 2022 merci d'être là
tous les deux une réaction tout d'abord
à ce qu'on vient de voir cet ambulancier
qui voilà qui est très malheureux
d'avoir perdu entre guillemets de son
travail qui pourtant est entré en
quelque sorte en résistance laurent
jacobellis ça vous inspire quoi ce type
de comportement moi je pense que le
gouvernement devrait avoir honte honte
de d'imposer à ceux qui nous ont soigné
parfois dans des conditions très
difficiles au début de l'épidémie
rappelez vous un compte il mettait des
sacs poubelle parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de blouse voit qu'il n'y avait pas
encore suffisamment de matériel de
protection ils sont allés au charbon
même malades parfois pour essayer
d'endiguer la pandémie et puis
aujourd'hui on les oblige se vacciner et
s'ils ne le font pas on leur demande de
rester chez eux grosso modo on les met
dans la voie du chômage dupré chômage
c'est inacceptable c'est inacceptable
parce que la personne que l'on voyait
dans votre reportage était d'accord pour
faire des tests et montrer qu'elle
n'avait pas l'accord vide donc ce n'est
pas une personne farfelues qui n'a pas
le sens des responsabilités mais vous
savez le gouvernement préfère attirer
l'attention sur ce personnel hospitalier
les montrer un petit peu comme des
renégats qui n'accepteraient par la
règle et mettrait en danger la vie
d'autrui alors qu'ils sont là pour la
sauver pour faire oublier ses propres
turpitudes vingt pour cent des lits
d'hôpitaux fermé par l'équipe de
monsieur verrons ça ça m'embête
s'installer jeunes vu un petit peu à la
baisse la ce week-end très bien
également bon est ce que vous croyez que
même s'il y avait eu deux lits
d'hôpitaux en moins ce serait normal
dans la pandémie tout ils ont non ses
5700 lits dont on parle est donc pour
faire oublier ça pour faire oublier
l'incurie et l'incompétence du
gouvernement et bien ce gouvernement
cherche des boucs émissaires mais vous
savez c'est pas en empêchant les gens de
travailler ce n'est pas en imposant le
masque aux gamins même qu'ils ne font
pas de maladies graves qu'on réglera le
problème c'est en investissant dans
l'hôpital c'est en contrôlant les
frontières en mettant des aérateurs dans
les classes tout ce que le gouvernement
était incapable de faire fi mazuel vous
ça vous inspire quoi beaucoup de
tristesse parce que je comprends la
détresse des gens qui n'ont pas envie de
faire vacciner quand même temps se font
sanctionner et je pense que il faut
mettre en oeuvre une pédagogie très
forte l'égard de ces personnes voilà et
surtout je crois que j'attends que le
président de la république de même à
demain quand il va s'exprimer apporte
des mesures fortes en faveur de des
soignants et enfer d'hôpital parce qu'il
ya un grand désespoir du personnel
soignant
face à la situation actuelle ils ont
effectivement perdu beaucoup de moyens
donc
j'attends aussi autre chose que vous
comprenez d'une certaine manière ça
tenterait en parce qu'il rentre en
résistance il est prêt à faire une grève
de la faim
ma liberté écoutez j'ai rencontré hier
en haute savoie une dame qui était très
affecté par le par le passé ni terre on
sentait qu'elle le prenais hackers
personnellement donc on peut pas on ne
peut pas juger les gens sur la façon
qu'ils reçoivent des instructions comme
ça mais enfin en tout cas cessé ses
prismes l'orangé comédie ont dit haut ce
soir à la haute autorité de santé
préconise de se passer du vexin de
modern art chez les jeunes on l'a appris
ce soir elle s'appuie sur le nouvel avis
de l'agencé européenne des médicaments
ils sont le rapport et piffard 1
confirmant le risque de mieux cardié de
péricardite pas très rassurant quand on
sait qu'on a fait vacciner nos enfants
et qu'on nous propose est au choix peur
ou moderna est ce que le gouvernement ne
participe pas justement à ces craintes
et à ce scepticisme
on peut comprendre la défiance des
français de certains français par
rapport au gouvernement et à sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire et par rapport aux
vaccins allaient nouvelle que vous
annoncez qui ne sont pas étonnantes
parce que c'est un vaccin nouveau et on
apprend en marchant rend nécessaire
d'appliquer la liberté vaccinale chacun
en son âme et conscience doit décider
quelle est pour lui le bénéfice entre la
différence par ton entre le bénéfice et
le risque qu'ils encourent en tout cas
dans un tel environnement le
gouvernement ne peut pas imposer il
vaccin ce serait déraisonnable et
malheureusement c'est ce que le
gouvernement actuel et monsieur veron
ont fait se passe sanitaire qui n'a
aucune autre utilité et finalement tout
le monde le reconnaît que de pousser les
français à se faire vacciner et bien est
une très mauvaise décision faisons
confiance dans le jugement des français
aujourd'hui ils sont 80% je crois à être
vaccinés que le gouvernement fasse
l'effort de vacciner les plus fragiles
et les plus anciens en essayant de leur
expliquer quels sont les bénéfices
risques mais qu'ils arrêtent de vouloir
entrer par la petite porte de
l'obligation vaccinale de le faire de
manière déguisée on le voit bien c'est
pas raisonnable vis-à-vis des nouvelles
qu'on a sur les vaccins même s'il faut
quand même le dire le vaccin joue un
rôle important dans le contrôle de cette
endémie niasse yeux qui n'est jamais
abordée et j'aimerais bien que présent
avec d'abord demain c'est
la vaccination du monde il ya 40 % des
citoyens du monde qui sont vaccinées
c'est à dire à peu près la moitié de la
france or si nous ne vaccinerons pas le
monde dans son ensemble en tout cas
évidemment les gens qui sont volontaires
nous allons avoir un retour de boomerang
donc ça c'est un point clé sur lequel
j'attendrai des annonces du président de
la république un autre point auquel sur
lequel j'aimerais aussi qu'il travaille
c'est la cohésion nationale parce que
nous sommes la veille du 11 novembre qui
est un moment de cohésion nationale et
je pense qu'il serait bon de faire
quelque chose en matière de précarité
énergétique et donc notamment ce que moi
je propose en tant que candidat à
l'investiture présidentielle c'est une
modulation des tarifs de l'énergie et de
l'eau en fonction des besoins c'est à
dire qu'on ne peut pas faire payer le
même prix pour l'eau et l'électricité
pour une douche il faut une piscine
quand ça c'est un autre débat qu'on a eu
d'ailleurs souvent sur ce plateau et
qu'on aura encore et qui sera
certainement effectivement vous avez
raison de souligner abordé demain par le
président de la république laurent jacot
possible
sur votre dernière remarque c'est vrai
que la france aussi elles sont en sort
mieux que les voisins européens que
l'allemagne par exemple ou les pays bas
concernant le taux d'incidence est un
parmi les explications on
nous présente les couvertures la
couverture vaccinale justement la france
vacciner à 76 % l'allemagne 2 69%
davantage de gestes barrières d'une
certaine manière il fallait peut-être
contrainte pour convaincre donc je ne
crois pas avec de bons résultats quand
même non je ne crois pas le résultat est
là les français sont largement vacciner
donc je pense que maintenant il faut
lâcher la bride aussi je peux me permets
de vous savez la liberté c'est quelque
chose une valeur cardinale dans notre
république française or aujourd'hui la
liberté de circuler la liberté
d'entreprendre la liberté de travailler
même ont été mises à mal à cause de
cette pandémie et on voit que le
gouvernement proroge de six mois en six
mois la possibilité de restreindre ses
libertés pour cause de pandémie jusqu'à
quand ça va durer jusqu'à la 5e 6e 7e
dan la troisième la quatrième et la
cinquième dose il y à un moment il faut
arrêter faire confiance aux français et
très honnêtement arrêter de leur faire
peur et disons le d'instrumentaliser
cette maladie pour imposer de nouvelles
règles aux français qu'il n'accepterait
pas autrement le président de la
république doit maintenant se rappeler
qu'il est président d'une nation qui a
été un phare pour la liberté du monde et
qu'ils doivent arrêter d'avoir comme
obsession de restreindre la liberté des
français c'est vrai en matière vaccinale
mais c'est vrai sur plein d'autres
sujets que nous pourrions évoquer ici
alors on va les faire à part donner moi
filmer l on va aller faire un petit
détour vers vers nos messages télégramme
des réactions rien qu à la question de
savoir ce que vous attendez du discours
de micron sont demain rien il va
probablement encore revenir sur des
promesses passées ou encore ne rien
faire laquelle il reviendra lors d'une
prochaine élocution justement philippe
mazuel sur ses libertés
ils le passent sanitaire ça va durer
jusqu'au 31 juillet enjamber la
présidentielle ça ça vous pose problème
vous ce sont le nouveau président de la
république décidera c'est pas monsieur
mac on ne peut pas imposer à son
successeur une politique donc il est
évident que l'eau on peut toujours
proposer d'enjamber mais l'échéance
d'avril sera fondamental moi ce que
j'attends aussi demain du président
république puisque nous sommes à la
veille de la présidence française et là
je rebondis sur ce qu'a dit
mon collègue tout à l'heure
représentant le ration de la sorte c'est
que c'est que il a il a critiqué
l'ouverture des frontières moi j'attends
au contraire du président la république
qu'il à la veille de la présidence
française qu'il annonce une un bon
politique un bon bein europe une
république européenne et de répliques
fédéral sociale environnementale qui est
le seul moyen pour nous pour la france
de continuer à exister dans un monde qui
va être dominée par les super puissances
que sont la chine les etats-unis et
d'autres demain matin voilà et je crois
que c'est aussi le seul moyen que nous
aurons pour garder notre siège au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies le
range la comédie oui vous en attendez
quoi de cette allocution ça se sert et
que c'était un petit peu la surprise il
parle assez tôt emmanuel macron
certainement satisfait xi sur le quoi
qu'il en coûte encourager les personnes
peut-être à la troisième dose allez
soyons fous rêvons un peu imaginons un
président de la république qui demain
fasse son mea culpa mea culpa sur la
politique migratoire qui a été un fiasco
avec un record historique du nombre deux
migrants légaux ou illégaux qui arrivent
sur le territoire national à chaque fois
chaque année qu'il fasse son mea culpa
sur l'économie puisque le pouvoir
d'achat des classes françaises moyenne
ou les plus défavorisés baisse sans
cesse sans que le gouvernement ne trouve
de solution viendra sur le chômage a
réduit le pouvoir d'achat augmente et
c'est maintenant et je lui disais quoi
qu'il encaisse je lui dirais que c'est
dommage qu'ils sortent peu de l'elysée
pour aller à la rencontre des français
ils verraient que sa perception des
choses est fausse moi j'aimerais un
président de la république qui dit je me
suis trompé on va changer les choses
mais il ne le fera pas et c'est pour ça
que les élections présidentielles qui
arrivent sont importantes parce que vous
savez je suis porte parole de marine le
pen est elle le sera elle s'occupera du
pouvoir d'achat des français elle
s'occupera des retraités elle elle
s'occupera des étudiants et puis elle
elle contrôlera nos frontières pour que
ne passe plus ni les virus ni les
marchandises fabriquées à bas coûts à
l'autre bout du monde et qui met en
danger notre industrie ni bien sûr
l'immigrant cache pas du tout vous savez
chez vous vous avez une porte d'entrée
vous choisissez qui rentrent qui sort et
pour autant j'imagine que vous avez des
relations amicales et que vous voyez je
rebondissais sur le virus c'est vrai que
malheureusement ce virus malheureusement
passe parfois les portes sous les portes
mais c'est comme le nuage de tchernobyl
il devait y n'a jamais franchi la
frontière française vous savez donc
elles ont arrêté non tout ça n'est pas
tout ça n'est pas très sérieux je pense
que la france a besoin de rester un pays
ouvert on peut pas construire proposer
aux français une vision
que l'on retrouve dans le rétroviseur il
faut aller vers une ville qu à une
europe plus forte une europe qui sera
une europe puissance une robe dans
laquelle qui sera souveraine
véritablement pense que si on est plus
autour de la table nous serons au menu
donc pour exister il faut dissoudre la
france votre explication mais
rassurez-vous emmanuel macron le fait
donc vous devrez titre est une personne
à la science moi je suis capable à
francis très patriote et je vais
démontrer d'ailleurs par mon parcours et
parce que je suis patriote je suis
européen parce que justement la france à
la chine pas plus que le royaume uni qui
est dans une totale illusion en pensant
à globo le rituel halal le royaume uni
global je pense que la france a besoin
d'être de jouer un rôle clé et d'être un
moteur de la république européenne de
demain a lancé deux projets et c'est le
projet que je porte et que deux tiers
des français rejette vous savez je pense
que le problème de la france c'est aussi
l'union européenne qui lui imposent ses
normes qui lui impose ses lois qui lui
impose ces migrants vous savez l'europe
elle est là où elle ne devrait pas être
c'est-à-dire dans notre vie quotidienne
à s'immiscer sur la volonté nationale
mais elle n'est pas présente là où elle
devrait être elle est où l'europe dans
la recherche sur l'intelligence
artificielle ou là la collaboration des
nations pourrait être utile elle est où
l'europe pour défendre un certain nombre
de secteurs industriels que la chine est
en train de nous voler notamment sur
l'énergie de demain l'europe elle est
absente de ces grands défis l'europe
stratège n'existe pas en revanche
l'europe qui calibre la contour des
pommes et qui choisit la circonférence
des toilettes devait sceller la victoire
l'europe qui nous impose le rapatriement
chili de migrants dont les français ne
veulent pas dont nous ne voulons pas
parce qu'ils piochent dans les caisses
sociales et qui crée du chômage et
d'insécurité et bien cette europe là je
suis désolé de vous le dire elle nuit à
la france alors luna quelque chose d'une
europe des nations où les nations dans
le fait très bien su r balayer l'europe
qui est un bon et moi venons tous les
ans on applaudit la légion étrangère et
c'est la troupe la plus applaudie se
sont pas les français ils sont français
non par le sang reçu mais parle en
millions versés et bien dans les mérites
et les allocations sociales c'est une
grande différence et toutes les
personnes qui travaillent pour la france
qui soit marson qui toi qui as dit
infirmiers etc ce mérite notre respect
et doivent être considérées
bien sûr ça fermente comme comme le font
les légionnaires donc mais ceux qui
viennent
la sécurité et en touchant les aides
sociales retourner chez eux monsieur
nous serons d'accord là dessus que
j'imagine mais bien sûr mais je veux
dire que vous présentez ça comme une
généralité et puis vous vous donnez si
les chiffres en disant l'immigration
clandestine a beaucoup augmenté comment
pourrez vous mesurer l'immigration
clandestine puisque par définition
j'écoute gérard dahmane un ministre de
l'intérieur qui parle de 600 milles à
700 milles personnes voulaient
royalement de l'intérieur j'en ai en
tout cas je pense que votre vision de
l'europe et est une vision très
restrictive et que je vois pas comment
la france pourrait demain faire face aux
défis qui l'attendent en étant tout seul
donc je crois que nous devons travailler
ensemble avec nos alliés merci à tous
les deux on a un petit peu dépassé le
cadre de ce débat covin mais ma foi
c'était très bien on vous invitera pour
un débat sur l'europe
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
d'avoir était avec mon pour ce face à
face à vendre oui oui un dernier vous
grand jour c'est laurence novembre oui
donc n'oublions pas de données pour le
bleuet de france
mais c'est pour les anciens combattants
et victimes de guerre avant de nous
avant de nous quitter je me rappelle
notre appel à témoins puisqu'on parlait
du coc vides il y à quelques minutes
vous souvenez locaux vides à bouleverser
votre vie vous aussi écrivez nous à
l'adresse qui s'affiche sur votre écran
qu'en pensent les français qui plfr
tv.fr et dans ce contexte de reprise
épidémique la fédération hospitalière de
france réclament au gouvernement un plan
massif d'embauché l'accès aux soins pour
tous et toute déclaration qui fait suite
à la guerre des chiffres concernant la
fermeture des lits dans les hôpitaux
estelle farges
6% c'est le pourcentage de lit qui
seraient fermés à l'hôpital public
estimations de la fédération
hospitalière de france la fhf dans les
colonnes du jdd la tension est là mais
elle est beaucoup moins catastrophique
que ne l'avait estimé le conseil
scientifique début octobre cette
nouvelle estimation se fonde sur une
étude de la fhf le journal du dimanche
explique que dans 70 % des cas ces
fermetures de lits sont dus à un manque
d'infirmiers et des soignants sans
compter les nouvelles normes sanitaires
apparu avec le co vite qui ont contraint
les établissements à fermer des lits
supplémentaires
c'est cohérent avec les résultats de l'
enquête sur les ressources humaines dans
les hôpitaux que nous avons publié fin
août sur 350 établissements 4 5 % des
postes d'infirmiers était vacant
l'obligation de ne mettre qu'un malade
par chambre pour éviter la propagation
du virus est responsable de 24% des
fermetures actuelle la situation globale
est plus difficile qu'avant la pandémie
estime la fédération hospitalière de
france et elle pourrait s'aggraver car
la pression sur le personnel soignant
est toujours plus forte le président de
la fhf redoutent la perte de 4000
médecins généralistes sur les quatre
prochaines années si les mesures prises
lors du ségur de la santé et l'injection
de fonds publics ont permis de maintenir
le paquebot à flot il estime cependant
que ce n'est pas suffisant et réclame je
cite un new deal de la santé va-t-on
continuer à avoir la fréquentation de
ces urgences augmenté de 10% par an à
être le premier recours avant la
médecine de ville et la principale cible
des économies en matière de santé le
système inventé il ya 30 ans prend l'eau
il doit être repensé au ministère de la
santé on a commandé une étude la plus
exhaustive possible au sujet des
fermetures de lits dans les hôpitaux
olivier vers en lui même se rendra
d'ailleurs au salon annuel de la
fédération hospitalière de france ce
mardi 8 novembre pendant ce temps la
situation dans les hôpitaux restent
tendues et cela pourrait encore durer
ces prochaines semaines si l'on en croit
le ministère de la santé et c'est la fin
de cette émission rendez vous dès demain
20h pour un nouveau numéro d'ici là
n'oubliez pas de réagir de commenter
poser vos questions sur le télégramme rt
france prochain point sur l'actualité
dans une trentaine de minutes
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes ce qui nous alerte